(upbeat music)
- If you want a job,
jumping into people's content on LinkedIn,
and actually leaving a
thoughtful answer leads
to incredible job opportunities.
If you want to build, if
you're an entrepreneur,
the sooner you can start
building leverage for yourself
through content or through
the brand you're creating,
the better, but it's a
mindset conversation.
The one thing I can promise
is not going to do anything
for anybody here is playing it out
in your head and doing nothing.
Non action is the devastating thing.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] How do we follow the
$1.80 strategy in LinkedIn?
- So what he's referring to
is I put out something
a couple months ago,
maybe half a year ago
called the $1.80 strategy.
The way to win is to
listen and then contribute.
My point was, everybody was
trying to grow on Instagram.
It's such a big thing for everybody.
And I said, look, there's, you know,
it's kind of like getting into shape.
There's a right way to do
it and a wrong way to do it,
and I said the right way
to do it instead of like,
following, unfollow people or
what LinkedIn is a disaster.
Everybody just spams each
other in the inbox, right?
You guys know,
so I created something
called the $1.80 strategy,
which is really what I would do
if I didn't have the size of
the audience that I have now,
and it's actually what I
did do on Twitter in 2007.
My point was, and by the way,
anybody who has a physical
location, you can like,
you can search on Instagram
by interests, hashtags, right?
You can search by neighborhood.
You're going to Columbia, Maryland place,
you're going to places, right?
So I'm in into the search, right?
So this is gonna work for all
of you if you want to build,
so you just go to Columbia, Maryland,
and right now it's going to
show you all the top photos
and all the recent photos,
like you can search by every
photo in Melbourne, New Jersey,
some of wine library does,
and I said look at the photo
and then leave a comment,
that means something.
The first photo is like a dude
who's like looking real fucking
diesel and shit and so like,
(laughing)
I mean you could, you could like,
and this I'm not joking, I
would literally go in here
and be like swole post.
- [Audience] Right, right.
- I did it.
(audience laughing)
- Like just, you know,
for our liquor store,
like people like mowing
the lawn, we're like,
will literally be like, great Lawn,
do you want a beer after this?
Like, we'll make a joke
or, you know, and do that,
and I call that leaving your two cents
and then I said, do that 90 times a day,
you're gonna drop $1.80 a
day, two cents at a time,
nine top posts times 10
different hashtags every day,
and that will massively
build up your audience.
And that's your $1.80 strategy.
The way you can do that on LinkedIn,
the great thing that's
happened on LinkedIn now
is it's become a content platform.
As you guys know,
it's not just a utility
anymore to get a job,
there's a ton of content in there,
search things that matter to your world,
read the article,
then leave the best comment
in the comment section
and use all the attention
of that person's audience
by leaving a meaningful
thought in the guide.
Guys, it's so crazy how
very basic my advice is,
it's that, it's not easy to implement
and the same way that like staying
in good shape is not easy.
It's easier to not eat
well and not work out.
It's easier, but that's how I would do it.
You know, there's two ways
to really attack content,
produce it, or engage with it,
but most people when they engage with it
are like me, me, me,
you know, like, I just,
you see it all, right?
Like, people leave a comment like,
yeah, if you agree with
him, sign up for mine,
nobody gives a shit about that.
It's like all the guys
tonight in Vegas that try
to get people to go to their
room on the first word.
It's not going to work.
(audience laughing)
It is not going to work.
You're not that handsome.
Hey, guys, thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription,
whether it's A three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me,
I could really use your support.